the us-china trade war escalated over
the weekend with both sides lobbing
fresh tariffs on the others exports and
no trade deal inside the United States
is now imposing levees on in the ditch
on an additional one hundred twelve
billion dollars of Chinese exports while
Beijing is countering with retaliatory
tariffs on seventy five billion dollars
in US goods smart speakers headphones
and shoes are among the Chinese exports
likely to be made more expensive through
the u.s. tariffs Beijing meanwhile we'll
hit US crude oil with a five percent
tear now that's the first time the
commodity has been targeted in this
dispute and of course this isn't the end
of the levees the u.s. plans to raise
tariffs on two hundred fifty billion
dollars in Chinese exports to 30 percent
from the current twenty five and in
December a further 15 percent tariff on
Chinese cellphones laptops and clothes
that will mean that virtually all made
in China products will be subject to
tariffs in the US now take a listen to
what Donald Trump had to say about the
latest escalation we'll see what happens
but we can't allow China to rip us off
any words the country we can't allow
China to take 500 billion dollars a year
out of our country we can't do that now
for more on this let's talk to our
financial correspondent in Frankfurt
Julie bars Julie what's the reaction so
far well here in the market it's
surprisingly benign the message from the
tariffs will be sending ripples of fear
through the middle ston tier in Germany
through industry throughout Europe and
Asia but here in the markets it's a
relatively calm reception the DAX in
fact the market barometer for German
shares is treading water elsewhere in
Europe in England for example or in
Italy the shares are in fact going up
and in Asia in very center of where this
conflict is also located you're actually
seeing shares higher and
and that's part of the message too well
because there's such a moderate reaction
there was a very positive news from the
Chinese economy from the Purchasing
Managers Index that sort of mirrors the
sentiment and industry they're in
business and that's helping to mitigate
the effects of this Bulli if they if the
reaction is so mild today should we
assume that that means that there's an
optimistic outlook going ahead briefly
if you can with many people there is
talked to a capital market strategist
this morning has said look at the shares
here they're not signaling a recession
they're signaling we're expecting this
to come to some sort of flute solution
Donald Trump we just heard there's a
meeting in September people are looking
at that in the markets and they're
hoping of course that there will be a
positive outcome they know you never
know with Donald Trump but there are a
lot of people sitting on piles of money
the strategist has said if it comes to a
good end all right Lee borrows in
Frankfurt for us thank you now let's
take a deeper dive into this with
Gabrielle Falvo Maya he's president of
the Keele Institute for the world
economy here in Germany Gabrielle thanks
for joining us my first question
consumer spending as we've seen I
believe last week there was some very
very strong numbers about consumer
spending in the US do we really believe
then that these new tariffs which are
focused so much on consumer goods will
change American behavior well we should
not forget that the Chinese currency has
depreciated some 14 percent since April
last year and so imports from China of
toys Footwear textiles and so on have
actually become cheaper and now we have
those tariffs that make them more
expensive so on net the effects are
likely to be very very small and that I
think explains the positive consumer
sentiment in the United States to some
extent now looking beyond the US and
China had a tariffs like these affect
other economies like the EU Mexico
Canada maybe so there is certainly a
fear factor you know we see that when
Donald Trump talks about tariffs he's
able to act and impose those tariffs and
imposes a lot of uncertainty on everyone
investors hold back with their decisions
exporters think twice before they engage
into big contracts so this uncertainty
affects everyone including chairman
exporters to the world and particularly
to the United States of course but on
the other hand there is an upside
because if you know the Americans lock
out Chinese goods from their markets
that might be an opportunity for
European producers
so think about the Hawaii conflict
Ericsson and Nokia European companies
might sell more United States with
Hawaii's locked out so again it's an
ambiguous situation for certain products
certain firms the trade war actually
provides opportunities but for most of
them it's more than a risk it's more
risk
we're trump to lose his reelection in
2020 how easy would it be to undo
everything he's done with trade at this
point you see I think the key factor
here is really uncertainty trade policy
that has been assumed to be stable for
many many years has become a source of
instability and that will be very hard
to be undone we see that the trade
policy is used more widely in many more
countries not just the United States and
and so the chain is out of the bottle if
you like and any new president United
States will have to spend a lot of
political capital and a lot of time to
get the genie back into it so we have to
expect more trade policy and so
uncertainty even without a US president
Trump very briefly is China likely to be
persuaded by these tariffs very hard to
say everything depends on the political
costs of those tariffs and for the time
being we must say that the the Chinese
government has engaged into a fiscal
stimulus they can use the currency to
buffer the negative effects of those of
those tariffs if really the economy
takes a big hit that bigger hit than
what we have seen so far then I guess
there is there will be more flexibility
for Chinese side gabriele Felber Meyer
president of the kill Institute for the
world economy thank you very much you're
welcome